sur la pénurie de médicaments et les
choix de l'industrie pharmaceutique
française poursuit aujourd'hui ces
travaux par l'audition de Monsieur
Renaud Catelan
directeur de l'agence générale des
équipements et produits de santé qu'on
appelle ajps de l'Assistance Publique
des Hôpitaux de Paris il est accompagné
du docteur Claude Bernard pharmacien
responsable de l'établissement
pharmaceutique de l'APHP
comme son nom l'indique lajeps met en
oeuvre la politique de l'APHP en matière
d'équipement et de produits de santé
votre témoignage Monsieur le Directeur
et ainsi que
docteur est évidemment incontournable
contenu de la force de frappe de l'AP-HP
qui représente évidemment un nombre très
important d'établissements hospitaliers
je citerai quelques chiffres qui
témoignent parmi d'autres de la taille
critique de cet établissement public de
santé qui est de dimension européenne
sinon mondiale raison pour laquelle les
enseignements que nous pouvons retirer
de votre expérience sont précieux
l'APHP représente avec ses 38 hôpitaux
environ 10% de l'hospitalisation en
France accueillant chaque année plus de
8 millions de personnes malades elle est
aussi le premier employeur
d'Île-de-France or c'est à l'hôpital
nous a dit le président du comité
économique des produits de santé qu'il y
a le plus de pénurie
la gepse remplit 5 missions pour le
compte de l'APHP l'évaluation des
produits de santé l'achat de produits
dans le cadre de marché
l'approvisionnement centralisé et la
livraison des hôpitaux parisiens le
développement et la fabrication de
médicaments indispensables pour des
besoins non couverts par les
laboratoires privés la gestion
pharmaceutique des cliniques cette
approche intégrée de l'évaluation à
l'approvisionnement en passant par
l'achat vous donne une vision
centralisée et elle vous rend
particulièrement qualifiée pour répondre
à nos questions sur la prévention et la
gestion de ce phénomène de pénurie de
médicaments dont nul ne remet plus en
cause désormais le caractère chronique
sinon endémique je rappelle qu'un
rapport du Sénat en juillet 2018 avait
déjà mis en évidence cette l'acuité de
cette pénurie et nous étions à l'époque
car entre guillemets 800 médicaments en
pénurie nous sommes à environ entre 2500
et 3000 selon les chiffres
nous vous odinner tout d'abord en tant
que représentant d'une centrale d'achat
de produits de santé en milieu
hospitalier pour que vous évoquiez les
méthodes qui sous tentent la passation
des marchés publics en matière de
fournitures de médicaments et qui sont
régulièrement évoqués dans cette
question de pénurie ont été évoquées
devant nous des politiques d'achat et
des critères d'attribution dangereux
entre guillemets le phénomène des méga
appel d'offres hospitalier est en
notamment régulièrement pointé du doigt
ce problème est d'ailleurs bien
documenté notre collègue Jean-Pierre de
colle dans ce rapport de 2018 que je
citais précédemment souligné déjà que
notre politique de rationalisation des
achats de médicaments hospitaliers en
privilégiant la massification des appels
d'offres à entrer une rarection des
fournisseurs et la multiplication
subséquente des difficultés
d'approvisionnement vous nous direz si
ce phénomène demeure ou si nous sommes
sur la voie de sa résolution nous vous
entendons ensuite en tant que
responsable de l'établissement
pharmaceutique de l'AP-HP seul site
industriel public de fabrication de
médicaments avec celui de la Pharmacie
centrale des armées or concernant cette
autre mission centrale de la GEPS nous
sommes entre deux eaux d'un côté vos
capacités de production ont été louées
durant la crise de la covid dans le
domaine des préparations hospitalières
spéciales votre mobilisation réussie
dans la production en urgence de
préparation de
systracurium curare en rupture de stock
à ce moment là puisqu'on a eu vraiment
une rupture aiguë
a notamment été montré en exemple cette
expérience étant même pérennisée par
l'article 61 de la LFSS du pour 2022
dont le décret d'application est attendu
pour le second semestre 2023 d'un autre
côté laps vocation à suppléer les
laboratoires du secteur privé en cas de
rupture d'approvisionnement médicament
produit par ces derniers puisque
conformément à l'article
r5124-69 du code de la santé publique et
suivant un tournant pris à la fin des
années 1990 lajeps ne peut plus
fabriquer de médicaments qui disposent
déjà d'une autorisation de mise sur le
marché exploitée dans le secteur
concurrentiel
deux surcroît elle n'en aurait
semble-t-il pas ou plus les moyens
puisque comme la déplorer devant nous le
président de l'Académie nationale de
médecine je cite il est clair que
l'ajeps en tant que producteur de
médicaments a été fermé
ces équipements sont obsolètes elle n'a
plus les moyens de produire des
médicaments vous nous direz ce qu'il en
est du processus engagé par la PHP
depuis septembre 2018
d'externer d'externalisation des
activités de production de son
établissement pharmaceutique sachant
qu'entre temps nous avons eu la crise de
la covid derrière ce choix
dit de modernisation et de
transformation je maintiens les
guillemets aussi pour cette expression
qui revient à sous-traiter entièrement
les activités de production de la GEPS
ce profil semble-t-il avant tout des
motifs économiques vous le voyez les
questions sont nombreuses il y va de la
faisabilité d'une politique souveraine
du médicament
alors que le nombre de médicaments
connaissant des pénuries ou des risques
de pénurie ne cessent d'augmenter et que
l'hôpital loin d'être immune à ces
difficultés paraît en être tout
particulièrement affecté nous
souhaiterions donc que vous puissiez
dans un bref propos introductif
présentez votre analyse de la situation
actuelle
exposer la façon dont l'agence que vous
dirigez agit pour prévenir et gérer les
pénuries de produits de santé et nous
dire si les évolutions récentes de son
positionnement et de ses compétences
sont susceptibles d'aider la GEPS a
apporté une contribution essentielle à
la lutte que nous souhaitons victorieuse
contre la multiplication des ruptures
d'approvisionnement de Ce bien de
première nécessité qui est le médicament
j'y ajouterai d'ailleurs les politiques
de contingentement qui ne sont pas sans
poser des questions je donnerai ensuite
la parole à Madame Laurence Cohen
rapporteur de notre commission d'enquête
qui vous posera une première série de
questions
je précise que cette audition est
diffusée en direct sur le site internet
du Sénat et qu'elle fera l'objet d'un
compte-rendu publié avant de vous donner
la parole je dois vous rappeler qu'un
faux témoignage devant notre commission
d'enquête et passible des peines prévues
aux articles
434-13
434-14 et 434-15 du code pénal je vous
invite à prêter serment de dire toutes
les vérités rien que la vérité en levant
la main droite et en disant je le jure
monsieur catland
docteur Bernard
Monsieur le Directeur docteur vous avez
la parole
madame la Présidente
peut-être commencer par présenter le
volet à chat comme vous l'avez souligné
madame la Présidente l'agence générale
des équipements et produits de santé à
une mission d'évaluation et d'achat pour
le compte des l'ensemble des
établissements
de l'Assistance publique hôpitaux de
Paris
avec comme force principale une très
forte intégration vous l'avez souligné
entre cette fonction évaluation achat et
tout l'aval du processus
d'approvisionnement et de distribution
des médicaments et des produits de santé
à l'Assistance publique ou plutôt de
Paris peut-être commencer par une
précision en revendique le titre de
direction acheteuse et non pas de
centrale d'achat c'est je pense cela qui
nous distingue par rapport
au central aux opérateurs nationaux ce
qu'on qualifiés d'opérateurs nationaux
et qui ont contribué très fortement à la
massification des achats hospitaliers
c'est ces dernières années
donc comme je vous le disais une
direction acheteuse la massification à
l'échalapé ancienne historique
j'aurais du mal à la dater mais la
Pharmacie centrale des hôpitaux de Paris
et plus récidiculaire la mission
d'approvisionnement les tout autant
c'est une structure qui a déménagé de
façon successive mais qui a qui existe
depuis des dizaines d'années
et donc la massification on se fait pour
le compte des 37 établissements de
l'assistante et copieux de Paris ce qui
représente une masse significative pour
vous donner une idée le volume de marché
d'achat annuel couvrant à la fois les
dispositifs médicaux les médicaments et
les équipements bio musicaux se
rapprochent des 2 milliards d'euros
annuels
c'est un montant de marché mais
également de dépenses puisque comme je
vous disais on n'est pas seulement une
centrale de référencement qui construit
des marchés références des produits au
bénéfice de ces adhérents et à charge
sur les adhérents de
d'adhérer à ces marchés et de mobiliser
ces marchés ou pas
l'Assistance publique hôpitaux de Paris
les marchés passés par la GEPS
correspondent à des besoins réels
réellement mobilisés et donc sur ces 2
milliards de marchés derrière il y a
également 2 milliards de dépenses soit
réalisé directement par l'établissement
que je dirige par la GEPS on y reviendra
tout à l'heure dans le cadre de la
partie approvisionnement et distribution
soit directement par les sites de
l'Assistance publique hôpitaux à Paris
qui tire qui mobilise les marchés que
nous avons passé en centrale
donc massification donc j'insiste
vraiment sur ce terme direction
acheteuse et non pas centrale d'achat
nous avons un taux de couverture de nos
marchés
de façon centralisée
qui avoisine qui couvre quasiment 100%
des médicaments de consommer à
l'Assistance publique ou plutôt de Paris
donc c'est environ 4000 références
4000 références au total
donc la quasi-totalité je pense de ce
qui existe comme référence de
médicaments hospitalier
donc un taux de couverture de 99,9% sur
les médicaments il y a une petite
proportion qui est laissée auprès du
grossiste répartiteur qui correspond au
traitement personnel des patients qui
sont hospitalisés qui va falloir
pérenniser
une massification donc un toute
couverture d'achat centralisé qui couvre
près de 95% des consommations de
dispositifs médicaux réalisés à
l'Assistance publique et sur ce qu'on
appelle les dmdive donc les consommables
de laboratoire nous sommes après de 90%.
donc comme vous voyez comme le constatez
une très forte concentration des achats
couvrant les besoins de l'Assistance
publique hôpitaux de Paris pour un
montant comme je vous l'ai indiqué
d'environ 2 milliards d'euros annuels
c'est une direction acheteuse parce que
la force ce monde de la geppe c'est
l'intégration de des établissements de
l'Assistance publique au sein de la
structure donc nous avons depuis
plusieurs années un projet ici à intégré
qui nous permet de connaître toutes les
consommations de l'ensemble des sites
et de connaître les stocks disponibles
dans les pharmacies à usage intérieur
les pays de nos établissements
donc on a la capacité lorsqu'on
construit nos marchés de s'engager sur
des quantités fermes on s'impose
la fixation d'un minimum et d'un maximum
de montant de marché
que l'on respecte
ce qui donne une visibilité pour
l'industriel puisqu'il sait exactement
sur ce à quoi il s'engage et en termes
de maximum et donc il sait qu'on va pas
aller au-delà de d'une quantité
déraisonnable et de la même façon à
l'extrême inverse il sait qu'il peut
compter sur un minimum de montant de
marché si il lui faut développer une
capacité de production ou s'engager sur
sur un prix donc cette intégration des
établissements de la paix au sein de
l'Assistance publique nous permet
vraiment d'avoir cette visibilité
on connaît nos consommations donc on
connaît nos besoins en termes de volume
on connaît nos besoins également sur les
nouvelles molécules ou sur les nouveaux
dispositifs médicaux grâce au travail de
la commission médicale de la Commission
du médicament et des dispositifs
médicaux stériles
puisque chaque nouvelle référence
molécules ou au dispositif médical fait
l'objet d'un décision de référencement
de non-référencement par cette
commission qui est une sous-commission
de la commission médicale
d'établissement en central et qui
regroupe à la fois définition de toutes
discipline et des pharmaciens ce qui
permet chaque fois d'avoir des décisions
plus ridisciplinaires collégiale donc
qui nous garantissent un minimum
d'objectivité qui
nous permettent aussi de prévenir tout
conflit d'intérêt qu'on a tout un
système de déclaration de liens
d'intérêt ce qui fait que voilà on a
vraiment cette organisation très
intégrée je pense unique en France donc
certes massification de nos achats à
hauteur de 10% de l'hospitalisation
française comme vous l'avez souligné
madame la Présidente
mais en même temps sur une connaissance
du besoin très fin un engagement sur les
quantités
on s'engage également sur les
calendriers donc nos soumissionnaires
les industriels qui répondent à nos
appels d'offres à nos marchés négociées
les procédures de choix d'élaboration
des cahiers des charges et de choix sont
très longues on est sur un délai moyen
de 12 mois donc 12 mois avant le
renouvellement d'un marché pour tel ou
tel produit on a un calendrier on
sollicite nos fournisseurs et on
construit nos marchés donc une assez
bonne visibilité qui donnait et puis il
y a toujours un laps de temps bien sûr
respecté entre la notification du marché
auprès de l'industrie qui a été
sélectionné et la passation de la
première commande
donc voilà là on est sur la partie on va
dire évaluation achat et puis très vite
on passe sur cette fameuse intégration
avec le processus approvisionnement et
distribution puisque au sein même donc
de l'agence générale c'est qu'ils m'ont
éroduit de santé nous avons une activité
évaluation à chaque et confiait une
pharmacie usage intérieure qui se situe
sur ces deux Paris et on a nous avons
une deuxième pharmacie à usage
intérieure sur le site de Nanterre qui
est chargée de cette fameuse
approvisionnement stockage et
distribution et donc le fait que ça
cohabite au sein d'un même établissement
sous une même direction et
même communauté pharmaceutique on va
dire permet bien sûr des échanges
renforcés donc on a ce continuum une
fois que le marché est notifié les
produits sont référencés dans nos
systèmes d'information qui est unique et
les passations de commande peuvent être
générés par le service approvisionnement
à distribution de la plateforme
logistique de Nanterre
donc ça c'est finalement le
fonctionnement en routine
qui donne cette fameuse visibilité à
l'industriel
en situation de tension et de rupture
cette organisation intégrée est
également une chance puisque
la plateforme logistique qui va passer
les commandes au fournisseurs très vite
être informés ou constaté que les
commandes qui passent ne sont pas
intégralement honorés ou que les délais
d'approvisionnement sont allongés
et donc il y a toutes ces un dialogue
qui se met en place bien sûr et une
échelle importante puisqu'on fait on
génère des problèmes importants mais il
y a très vite un échange également entre
la plateforme logistique de Nanterre et
le service évaluation achat qui situe
sur Paris et puis le cas échéant on
partage assez facilement l'information
avec avec la NSA notamment
qui dit rupture ou tension
d'approvisionnement déceler de façon
assez précoce dit mise en place de
contingencement donc là aussi le fait
que l'on ait une plateforme unique qui
alimente la totalité des satismes de la
PHP avec un système d'information unique
le fait que l'on connaisse
les stocks disponibles dans les
vingtaine de pays de formation usage
intérieur de la PHP nous permet de
choisir à qui on distribue les produits
le fait que l'on connaisse également
l'activité des sites ça a été le cas
pendant le covid alors c'est
relativement simple entre guillemets
puisque les patients étaient concentrés
en réanimation et en soins intensif mais
on avait la capacité de connaître
exactement le nombre de patients dans le
nombre de lits on avait la possibilité
donc de faire du contingentement et
d'attribuer les produits sous tension ou
proche de la rupture en fonction de la
localisation des patients et de
l'activité réelle plutôt que du stock
qui qui dormait donc on a cette
possibilité de distribuer voire de
redistribuer donc il est pas rare que on
demande à une pays de dépanner la PI
voisine encore une fois parce qu'on est
dans la même institution qui a une
entité juridique unique et une certaine
solidarité au sein de l'établissement
en collant un petit peu le dispositif et
la force de
l'assistante de l'organisation
historique de l'assistance publique
cette agence donc il y a une direction
qui est à la fois évaluage et distribuer
et donc gère cette la gestion des stocks
et sa distribution
peut-être quelques commentaires
complémentaires sur la façon alors si on
revient sur la façon d'acheter
comme je vous j'ai essayé de vous
l'expliquer en la massification à la
paix s'accompagne de
montant de marché et de quantité appelée
qui sont qui sont fermes qui sont connus
des calendriers de notifications de
marché de mobilisation des marchés qui
sont connus à l'avance
l'existence de la plateforme pardon j'ai
sauté ce point-là
mettre à disposition du de l'industrie
et des industriels un point de livraison
unique donc plutôt que en tout cas sur
le médicament donc plutôt que un
industriel fasse le tour des 37
établissements il ne livre que le site
de Nanterre un charge pendant ensuite de
distribution ce qu'il y a aussi des
conséquences en termes de développement
durable et de logistique du dernier
kilomètre
mais voilà on essaie de donner un
maximum de lisibilité et de perspective
à nos fournisseurs
ce qui est également précieux en
situation de crise ou bon quand on
change de produit quand on fait on
trouve une équivalence hérétique ou
qu'on change de fournisseur parce qu'on
n'a pas la totalité des produits auprès
de un fournisseur en marché
très vite il y a une de la visibilité il
est très facile ou plus facile de livrer
en point plutôt que plutôt que des
dizaines
sur les procédures de marché on fait
bien sûr du la gestion
de multi attributaires ou de l'eau
identique sur les produits sensibles
donc on le fait historiquement on le
fait on l'a fait si historiquement sur
près de 10% de nos références de
dispositifs médicaux
là souvent en raison de la taille du
marché de la php par rapport à des
fournisseurs qui sont de plus petites
tailles que les industriels de
médicaments donc il est pas rare que
pour même type de référence un même type
de dispositif médical on fasse plusieurs
lots identiques ce qui nous permet de
diversifier nos sources
d'approvisionnement et on le fait on l'a
fait on le fait de plus en plus souvent
et donc c'est un début de réponse
pratiquée pratique et à la paix mais bon
c'est une bonne pratique qui est
largement partagée on le fait également
sur médicaments donc
on le fait sur des on l'a fait sur du
curare ou sur les hypnotiques on l'a
fait de façon systématique sur les
immunoglobulines polyvalentes
c'est un vieux sujet de tension donc on
a il y a encore une dizaine d'années on
a toujours fonctionné avec deux
fournisseurs pour le même type de
produit le marché en cours d'exécution
et
attributeur enfin
bénéficie à trois fournisseurs et le
marché qui est en cours de négociation
et de publication
sera notifié à quatre fournisseurs donc
on a cette démarche de
chaque fois que c'est possible de
multiplier de diversifier nos sources
approvisionnements après c'est toujours
compliqué je pense que c'est quelque
chose qui est largement partagé par les
hospitaliers et notamment au sein de la
paix où il y a une multitude
d'établissements et où les personnels
vont circuler d'un établissement à
l'autre multiplier les références et
aussi multiplier
les risques sanitaires et les risques
d'erreurs puisque le personnel est formé
c'est partiment pris sur le dispositif
médical mais c'est aussi vrai sur les
poches dont on a parlé dans l'actualité
de façon récente voilà les personnels
sont fermés on change la poche on change
de dispositif d'injection il faut
reformer les personnels il faut
potentiellement adapter nos automates
donc voilà on le fait c'est une démarche
qui est dynamique mais on le fait avec
parcimonie et en connaissant voilà les
risques qu'on prend et l'accompagnement
que cela nécessite et puis là aussi on
compte aussi sur les industriels puisque
quand on diversifie nos sources
d'approvisionnement on insiste sur la
nécessité qui nous accompagne dans
pense à répondre à la plupart des
aspects
achats on a beaucoup reproché
la
on a beaucoup reproché aux Hospitaliers
également le recours aux exécutions aux
fraises
dont on dit que
il contribue à aux pénuries à la mise en
difficulté des fournisseurs
c'est pas une opinion que nous
partageons pour nous c'est un outil
indispensable de responsabilisation de
l'industriel
et pour nous une garantie de trouver un
industriel de substitution donc c'est le
mécanisme ou quand un fournisseur qui
est retenu au marché et défaillants on
s'adresse donc en général à l'industriel
qui est classé en numéro 2 quand c'est
de la concurrence et puis la différence
de prix est facturée et opposable au
fournisseurs titulaires du marché qui
est défaillant donc encore une fois
c'est pour nous assez dissuasif
vis-à-vis de l'industriel qui certaines
fois s'engagent sur des quantités ou sur
un nouveau produit
dont on peut douter au moment de sa
réponse à l'appel d'offre qui sera en
capacité de répondre aux besoins mais
bon on est en marché public donc l'offre
est telle qu'elle est donc on est obligé
d'accepter mais voilà il est pas rare
que six mois après la signature du
marché le fournisseur soit défaillant
encore une fois nous considérons que
c'est plutôt quelque chose de
responsabilisant pour les fournisseurs
sachant qu'on en use avec parcimonie
pendant la crise de covid on n'a pas
facturé les différents scènes donc ça
reste à la charge de la pile voilà on le
fait de façon ponctuelle mais mais on
souhaite continuer à disposer de ce
dispositif
et puis dernier point la richesse de
cette direction acheteuse mais on a déjà
un petit peu évoqué c'est l'évaluation
et le bon usage donc au sein de de la
Commission du médicament et des
dispositifs médicaux
médicaux il y a tout ce travail de
référencement mais également de
préconisations du bon usage donc de
façon routinière encore une fois on
utilise que les dispositifs médicaux les
ou les molécules strictement
indispensables à la PHP donc très
clairement nos référence pas tout ce qui
apparaît sur le marché plus ou moins
innovant et puis en situation de crise
on a cette capacité à mobiliser l'expert
du comédiemes pour prioriser les
pathologies les patients les plus lourds
et trouver des solutions substitution
pour la prise en charge des patients qui
nécessitent moins entre guillemets bien
sûr
très bien merci beaucoup je vais donc
demander à notre rapporteur de
poser une première salle de questions
oui merci madame la Présidente merci
Monsieur catland on voit que dans votre
présentation la GEP c'est un outil
précieux et que son rôle est fondamental
et on l'a vu encore lors de la crise de
la de la covid
moi j'aimerais peut-être
approfondir les questions un certain
nombre de questions d'ailleurs que la
présidente vous avez posée on a vu que
pendant la crise de covid il y avait de
la covid il y avait une pénurie des
curare et vous vous avez pu répondre en
partie avec la production de 6 à
traquurium pas très facile à prononcer
et est-ce que finalement ça vous paraît
susceptible d'être répliqué alors
pendant la crise je pense que la réponse
va être positive mais hors crise
c'est-à-dire que est-ce que vous pensez
pouvoir répliquer ce genre donc de de
production pour permettre
de répondre aux besoins aux besoins des
patients et peut-être approfondir un
petit peu parce que pour cette
production spécifique là de ce cura vous
avez dû faire appel en fait à de
nombreux acteurs aussi bien public que
privés donc comment est-ce que vous avez
réussi à à mettre tout ça en mouvement
puisque il y avait outre la Jef
façonnier etc etc donc voilà j'aimerais
avoir des des précisions sur cette sur
cette cet aspect des choses et
finalement on a vu aussi au cours au
cours du temps que
la GEP se fabriquait historiquement des
médicaments qui étaient donc développés
par la PHP ou parce que c'était des
médicaments qui n'étaient pas poursuivis
par les industriels et
il semblerait que vos moyens étaient
considérablement diminués ce qui fait
que vous ne produisez plus ou presque
plus de médicaments alors comment est-ce
qu'on en est arrivé à cette politique-là
qu'elles ont été les choix est-ce que ce
sont des choix qui sont purement d'ordre
économique et c'est pour ça que que
cette production de médicaments a été
arrêtée est-ce que c'était parce que
c'était une production qui rentrait en
concurrence avec le secteur privé et ça
rejoint un autre aspect des choses c'est
que dans la dans la dans la plus récente
période vous avez eu recours à
externaliser l'ensemble de vos de vos
productions donc comment est-ce qu'on
peut expliquer ça parce que on voit bien
que notamment en période de crise la GEP
c'est un outil mais si il est il est
affaibli cet outil devient beaucoup
moins performant qu'il ne pourrait
l'être et on peut aussi imaginer que la
GEPS pourrait avoir un rôle hors crise
parallèlement d'ailleurs au secteur
privé pour permettre de de
dépasser donc ces ruptures donc ça
c'était une série de de questions qui
ont qui ont toutes des points communs
qui sont sur la même la même logique
maintenant ma deuxième série de
questions c'est est-ce que au niveau de
la GEF vous continuez à développer de
nouvelles molécules puisque normalement
son rôle initial le rôle initial de la
GEF c'était le développement de
nouvelles molécules donc est-ce que vous
continuez à le faire
et en quoi est-ce qu'il y a une
plus-value que de recourir de manière
généralisée à la sous-traitance
qu'est-ce qui qu'est-ce qui est qui
apparaît comme un élément positif ou au
contraire négatif
[Musique]
par ailleurs vous avez eu votre
portefeuille de médicaments qui s'est
beaucoup réduit là encore quels ont été
les choix pourquoi il a été réduit
est-ce que ce sont des raisons
économiques est-ce que ce sont d'autres
d'autres raisons et qu'elles sont
finalement
y a-t-il des avantages à la réduction de
ce portefeuille et quelles sont les
inconvénients que vous avez pu que vous
avez pu mettre en lumière et enfin
quelles sont les enfin j'ai encore deux
questions quelles sont les grandes
lignes du du votre mode opératoire
là où il s'agit d'assurer la continuer
la continuité des soins malgré les
ruptures d'approvisionnement
c'est-à-dire tout ce qui est travail au
niveau des équivalences thérapeutiques
recherchent de traitement de
substitution pour les patients concernés
émission de recommandation etc je vais
pas faire la liste vous la connaissez
donc quelle est la politique que vous
que vous conduisez et ma dernière ma
dernière question qui rejoint finalement
la série de de mes questions
celles que j'ai j'ai faite au début dans
un rapport qui a été publié en 2021 nous
avons un certain nombre de nos collègues
députés qui étaient donc rapporteurs de
la mission d'information sur les
médicaments et qui préconisaient la mise
en place en France sous pilotage public
d'une structure analogue au groupement
sans but lucratif états-unien sivica et
il proposait que l'établissement
pharmaceutique de la PHP joue pour le
compte des pouvoirs publics en quelque
sorte
les pouvoirs publics le rôle de
coordinateur de de ce réseau est-ce que
vous ça vous semble quelque chose de de
possible et je le dis d'autant plus que
je vous ai ça fait au moins la troisième
fois que je vous auditionne puisque
effectivement vous savez quels sont les
travaux que j'ai produits sur cette
question je vous remercie
je suis directeur docteur je sais pas
qui répond c'est le directeur
en partant du tout début et l'aventure
du 6 attract curium
en introduction et puis on va revenir
sur les chocs qui ont été faits sur
l'établissement de la pêche HP et puis
on reviendra sur sur les perspectives et
ce qu'on envisage de faire le 6 attrape
curium
c'est un bel exemple et c'est la
confirmation de la conviction que l'on
avait que l'on a
qu'on n'y arrivera pas tout seul et
qu'au vu de l'ampleur de des difficultés
qui voilà sont multifactory je crois que
les différents
intervenants aux personnes que vous avez
auditionné
l'ont bien exprimé on irait on n'y
arrivera pas tout seul et donc c'est une
activité collective ça a été plutôt un
succès
et comme vous l'avez dit on a à la fois
travaillé avec du public du privé sous
le haut patronage ou l'Égypte de la DGS
et la NSM qui ont été extrêmement
proactifs sur sur ce sujet là et Claude
Bernard sans doute vous décrira un petit
peu la façon dont on a procédé et les
délais que l'on a réussi à tenir mais
encore une fois on y serait pas arrivé
tout seul
et c'est un petit peu ça que l'on se
propose de mettre en oeuvre pour
l'avenir
si on revient en arrière donc septembre
2018 choix fait
d'arrêter la production et le contrôle
qualité réalisé en régie donc dans nos
ateliers et dans nos laboratoires de
contrôle
juste une question qui a fait le choix
la direction générale de laquelle tout à
fait
un choix multifactoriel pas pas
économique ou pas pas principalement et
économique loin de là premier facteur le
corpus réglementaire donc dans les
spécificités et une des forces de
l'établissement pharmaceutique de la PHP
c'est d'être un établissement
pharmaceutique soumis aux bonnes
pratiques de fabrication en BPF
et inspecté par l'Agence nationale de
sécurité du médicament à la différence
des autres lieux de hospitaliers de
fabrication de mes médicaments qui sont
les pays pardon pharmacie usage
intérieures qui fabriquent des
préparations hospitalières mais sous un
corpus réglementaire et de niveau de
qualité
les deux bonnes pratiques de préparation
et qui est pas du tout elle-même auteur
et donc la force de l'établissement
pharmaceutique était aussi une
contrainte on se retrouver à exercer nos
activités pour nos productions à la fois
correspondant à des AMM donc des
autorisations de mission de marché sur
des produits comme le faire ou le font
de l'épisol et également sur tous nos
autres produits qui sont des
préparations hospitalières
mais un produit à échelle industrielle
ce qui fait que devait être produit au
sein de l'établissement pharmaceutique
et soumise à ses règles de bonnes
pratiques de fabrication et ces règles
sont extrêmement rigoureuses années
après année
on a des lignes directrices qui se
cumulent
qui sont qui sont arrêtés au niveau
européen désormais au niveau de l'EMA et
qui sont pas forcément complètement
adaptés on va dire à nos productions qui
comme vous disiez sont des petites
productions en volume correspondant à
des produits historiques développés à
l'Assistance publique au départ dans les
pharmacies à l'intérieur et donc des
produits qui ont pas forcément toutes
les phases de développement toute la
complétude des dossiers pharmaceutiques
permettant d'aller jusqu'à la MM
on produit dans nos ateliers on
produisait dans nos ateliers on a un
référentiel de 40 produits un peu plus
de 40 produits la moitié était déjà
sous-traitée l'autre moitié était fait
dans nos ateliers mais voilà c'est c'est
des productions qui en général
correspondent à deux ou trois Léo
annuels sur 20 références c'est sur les
mêmes automates ça nécessite des
nettoyages constants des réglages de
machine constant donc voilà encore plus
réglementaire un niveau de qualité qui
correspond et qui nous était appliqués
dans toute sa leur rigueur de façon
réglementaire qui correspondait pas
forcément à nos produits donc ça c'est
le premier élément c'est qu'on
n'arrivait pas à trouver un statut
intermédiaire entre nos productions très
spécifiques qui relevaient par leur
nature de préparation hospitalière mais
qui était à l'échelle industriels par
leur volume et donc pas de nos moyens de
termes entre le statut et même et le
statut préparation hospitalière locale
c'est première raison donc cette course
à la
à la qualité et au respect du
référentiel mais qui encore une fois est
aussi une engage de qualité une force
pour l'établissement pharmaceutique
deuxième motif du choix c'est comme vous
l'avez dit une diminution de notre
nombre de références produits parce
qu'on est on est légaliste que le statut
de l'établissement pharmaceutique et de
produire que ce qui n'est pas disponible
auprès des industriels enfin de
l'industrie pharmaceutique
et que sur la période de la série
récente on a vu apparaître de plus en
plus de d'industrie lors des petites
sociétés qui ont été intéressées par nos
produits et qui sont proposés de
reprendre ses productions
de contribuer à les mener à
l'autorisation de mise sur le marché
et elle est diffuser hors de France
puisque la vocation de l'EP c'est de
c'est un établissement à vocation
nationale à ressemble nationale mais il
y avait pas vocation à faire des
autorisations de mission de marché pour
l'Europe donc bien évidemment chaque
fois qu'on a un industriel qui vient
nous voir et nous dit il y a des besoins
en Allemagne et des besoins en Italie
c'est pas satisfait votre produit
nos intérêts et pour y soigner des
patients voilà et réglementairement
législativement et puis et puis
philosophiquement éthiquement on
considère que on trouve ce partenaire on
construit un partenariat on fait une
licence de savoir-faire et puis et puis
finalement il exploite notre produit il
prend il prend notre produit c'est un
peu la vocation en tout cas les
établissement pharmaceutique avait été
créé pour ça et pourquoi on a de plus en
plus d'offres de d'industrielles c'est
notamment parce que on est sur des
créneaux de maladies rares la
réglementation sur la fixation des prix
a évolué depuis une dizaine d'années et
que dès lors qu'un médic maintenant
reçoit la désignation orpheline il y a
un système de fixation des prix je pense
que les personnes additionnées
précédemment le Romieu explique que moi
il y a cette possibilité d'avoir des
prix intéressants et donc on retrouve
des industriels qui par définition
c'était des produits de niche peu de
quantité parentables le système de
fixation des prix au titre de la maladie
ophonie orphelin fait que on a eu des de
l'intérêt industriel et encore une fois
on se sentait pas légitime et pas
réglementairement autorisé abandonner
ses productions
ce qui permet aussi de répondre à une de
vos questions aujourd'hui le statut de
l'établissement pharmaceutique ne nous
permet pas d'aller faire de la
concurrence par rapport à l'industrie et
l'établissement n'a jamais été créé pour
ça
c'est pas forcément ce sur quoi on se
projette
troisième élément c'est que
la capacité de production reste quand
même réduite les formes galéniques ont
évolué et donc
même si l'outil est tout à fait
fonctionnel et moderne en fonction de
sur des ampoule standard c'est de plus
en plus du flacon ou de la poche
on est limité en taille de comprimé en
type de gélules donc voilà il y avait un
manque de souplesse et un besoin de
d'extension mais alors pas seulement des
équipements c'était des miroirs qui fait
que la PHP avait pas forcément vocation
pas vocation à investir massivement
pour pour cet outil avec cette
conviction que de toute façon le besoin
se diversifier les formes galéniques se
diversifient et que un opérateur unique
public ou privé satisfaitait jamais la
totalité du besoin
et puis après un sujet conjoncturel
immobilier l'élaboratoires étaient
situés sur Paris il y a un projet de
session de partiel et donc il aurait
fallu déménager ses laboratoires
reconstruire un laboratoire de contrôle
avec les groupes
engendrer mais encore une fois c'était
vraiment un sujet marginal pour pour la
décision donc décision de stratégique
c'était conviction de pas pouvoir tout
faire et adapter l'outil de façon assez
souple à toutes les formes qu'il aurait
fallu remplir ou satisfaire
de moins en moins de produits on va
revenir sur la recherche et
développement et puis et puis cette
contrainte réglementaire et qualitative
qui était quand même un très très forte
puisqu'on en y est donc les nouvelles en
même temps qui a été pris cette décision
donc d'externalisation on a fait le
choix de renforcer la R&D donc ça c'est
traduit par de nouveaux moyens on a
renforcé des équipes
ça représente à peu près un cinquième ou
un quart d'effectifs en plus par
déploiement il ambition et bien donc on
a un département de recherche et
développement gallini qui analytique et
l'ambition est bien de continuer
l'aventure de l'établissement
pharmaceutique donc faire ce qu'on a
toujours fait aller chercher auprès du
clinicien une idée alors c'est ça le
repositionnement d'une molécule
soit donc on passe une indication à une
autre indication ou utiliser une changer
de forme galénique et trouver une forme
galénique plus adaptée au grand âge ou à
la pédiatrie
pour développer un nouveau produit et
donc actuellement on a une dizaine de
projets qui correspondent à se
repositionnement de molécules
sur le choix stratégique en
externalisation de production donc
encore une fois contrairement à ce qui a
pu être dit par l'Académie
l'établissement ne ferme pas
nous sous traitons donc je généralisons
la sous-traitance qu'on faisait sur la
moitié de nos produits on le fait sur la
totalité mais encore une fois enfin
voilà c'est un choix assumé avec cette
conviction donc c'est une façon d'avoir
plus de souplesse de pouvoir s'appuyer
sur des façonniers qui
tous dispose de la totalité des formes
galéniques et des outils de production
dont on aurait besoin plutôt que de
courir après une usine de production
qu'on n'arrivait jamais à niamenter ni
entretenir ni adapter suffisamment
rapidement par rapport aux besoins alors
bien sûr la sous-traitance a des
contraintes c'est il faut un temps quand
même pour choisir nos sous-traitants
nous sommes établissements publics donc
on fait tout cela dans le cadre de
marché public donc on met en concurrence
nos sous-traitants on prend les
offres les plus intéressantes et les
plus performantes techniquement quand on
a le choix on l'a pas forcément toujours
en tout cas sur nos produits qui sont
encore une fois j'avais essayé de vous
l'expliquer des produits un peu
atypiques souvent compliqué à faire
finalement
mais voilà cette idée c'est quand même
de non pas à fermer l'établissement
informatique le pérenniser sur nos
productions actuelles et puis les
développer et multipliés potentiellement
soit à partir de notre R&D soit à partir
des demandes des pouvoirs publics de
pouvoir récupérer des nouvelles
productions et des nouveaux des nouveaux
produits
le schéma historique de l'établissement
pharmaceutique qu'on essaie de faire
perdurer il y avait donc en général
c'est un produit de enfin il y a deux
types d'activités c'est soit des
productions historiques
issues des idées des cliniciens de la
PHP
produites à l'échelle locale par les
pharmacies les agents dans un premier
temps et puis ensuite on centralise on
industrialise
et on distribue sur l'ensemble de la
France
et puis comme je vous l'expliquais donc
soit
une préparation hospitalière intéresse
un industrielle et là il y a un
transfert de savoir-faire et c'est
l'industriel qui qui dépose la MM donc
on a quelques success story la gamme
pediavène avec fraisinus cavy on a la
méthadone APHP avec Bouchard haricot
Datti voilà or fakol qui évite les
grèves de foi
avec cette RS ainsi de suite donc on a
une dizaine de partenariats ou de
produits en partenariat industriels qui
sont des produits historiques à PHP qui
ont été portés à la même avec notre aide
par des industriels
la licence de savoir-faire génère bien
sûr des redevances pour l'établissement
pharmaceutique ce qui nous permet de
financer notamment notre rdéd ou notre
outil de production de nos équipes
et puis on continue vraiment sur ce
schéma là donc vraiment cette capacité à
la fois
préparation hospitalière
industrialisation et passage dans le
statut de préparation hospitalière à la
même
et puis d'autres types d'activités
historique sur lesquelles on continue on
veut pouvoir continuer à se positionner
d'autant plus facilement que on aura un
éventail de sous-traitant développé et
de fournisseurs de matières premières
c'est toutes les sollicitations des
pouvoirs publics quand il manque une
molécule donc on revient on revient au
cœur du sujet donc lorsque
l'établissement ferme à ce type de
Libourne a fermé on a récupéré une
dizaine de leurs production
lorsque un industriel produisait un
médicament
cardiologique
c'est la production avec la NSM nous
demande de la reprendre hors indications
pour une frange limitée de malade qui
qui utilisent ce produit là
revendications pour une maladie rare on
reprend le produit donc voilà la cible
la stratégie que l'on souhaite
développer c'est poursuit de cette
activité là
dans les deux cas oui c'était on sait de
la NSM donc laps à l'époque qui était
venu à nos sollicités notamment pour la
mexicain pour le quart de plaisir
donc encore une fois le
externalisation des productions et du
contrôle qualité n'est pas n'est pas un
abandon des productions on reste
fabricants on souhaite développer nos
fabrications
l'expertise que l'on a en tant que
producteur encore aujourd'hui le projet
va se terminer d'ici un an normalement
un an et demi
le fait que l'on sous traite depuis des
années la moitié de production on fait
qu'on connaît très bien le tissu l'offre
des façonniers
on connaît les fournisseurs de matières
premières on est rompu aux audits
sous-traitants c'est tout un travail
pharmaceutique c'est pas juste en
contrat commercial le fait de
sous-traiter c'est plus compliqué que
sur la restauration sur une autre
activité Claude Bernard mieux que moi et
donc toute cette activité très
pharmaceutique et spécifique qui est dur
à trouver en France en là et on la
développe à l'occasion de ce projet
d'externalisation puisque désormais on
va fonctionner avec une dizaine de
sous-traitants de façon de façon
quotidienne
et puis on en vient du coup au projet de
6 à tracurium
la présidente Madame la rapporteur
mesdames et messieurs vous pouvez
raconter l'histoire de six attrackerium
est-ce qu'on pourrait avoir la dernière
slide s'il vous plaît
l'avant-dernière donc
c'est une histoire qui est issue de la
covid puisque je vais vous raconter
aussi la petite histoire
d'ici à tracurium j'ai eu un coup de fil
d'un collègue le lundi de Pâques en 2020
me demandant si l'établissement
pharmaceutique de la PHP pouvait
réceptionner stocker des principes
actifs qui étaient en tension
d'anesthésie principalement donc dont
l'écura le 6 ATRA Latra le Midas de
l'homme le propofol etc on en a parlé
avec Renault donc on a pris en stock on
a passé le marché en une demi-journée on
a acheté pour enfin pour le compte de
l'État plusieurs plusieurs principes
actifs pour plusieurs millions voilà et
puis assez rapidement effectivement sous
l'égide de la NSM et de la DGS c'est
poser la question de
fabriquer faire fabriquer par les
pharmacies à usage intérieur de certains
grands CHU
un de ces médicaments et puis bon voilà
le l'attention a été portée sur
l'écureur puisque c'était les produits
et le 6 attraps en particulier lorsqu'il
faut savoir sur le sixatra c'est qu'il
est très utilisé en dehors de
l'Assistance publique mais pas
l'Assistance publique c'est un public
les anesthésistes réanimateurs utilisent
de la traquarium et donc les pays se
sont mis à étudier la question de
fabriquer différentes formes injectables
de de six attracterium pour
venir en aide aux patients qui en
avaient besoin en cas de rupture etc
puisque effectivement ça sert à intuber
les patients qui ont besoin de
respiration artificielle et s'ils ont
pas ça vous voyez les conséquences que
ça peut avoir c'est à dire que nous on a
décliné à très rapidement
de fabriquer en propre pour répondre à
la question de l'US des ateliers puisque
pour éviter très spécifique il y aurait
alors j'ai pris la décision en tant que
pharmacien responsable de ne pas
fabriquer en interne le 6 attracts
curium d'abord un parce que c'est un
produit qui se conserveau froid et on
n'a pas les les possibilités de faire de
la fabrication à plus de plus 8 qui
demande une filtration stérilisante très
partition assez petit quoi là des
techniques qu'on a pas et deuxièmement
c'est un produit extrêmement actif je ne
peux pas mettre en oeuvre une
fabrication de six à tracursum sans
avoir validé le nettoyage et avoir les
précautions nécessaires pour manipuler
ce type de produits extrêmement toxique
et je peux pas dire que je vais
fabriquer sans avoir validé donc être
m'assurer que de nous assurer qu'il y a
pas de il y a plus de traces de six
attractérium dans le produit suivant
qu'on va fabriquer la moindre je vous
rappelle pas l'affaire enfin monsieur je
veux être mort ça rappelle encore d'ici
à très curium
donc oui pas possible de faire donc les
pays ont pris en charge et
développer effectivement des des
méthodes de fabrication et d'analyses en
fait la preuve de concept fin 2020 et
effectivement
en avril 2021 lajeps la NSM nous ont
demandé de faire fabriquer par Delphin
avec laquelle DGS avait des contacts
des ampoules de 6 attaques curium donc
on s'est entendu sur la formulation
finale donc 10 mg ml qu'est-ce que vous
avez comme ampoule en stock des ampoules
de 5 des ampoules de 10 des flacons bah
on a des ampoules de 5 on va faire du 5
donc ça fait du 50 mg et donc il y a eu
des échanges donc ça c'était en avril
2021 mi-avril 2021 et les premiers les
quatre lots étaient libérés fin juillet
enfin non même pas début juillet 2021
donc en deux mois et demi trois mois ce
qui sous le statut de préparation
hospitalière vous faites la même chose
avec une amie il faut au moins un an
voilà donc je pense que effectivement ça
a permis de sauver des vies
et puis donc la distribution l'a fait
prendre en charge par SPF pour la raison
que SPF est en relation avec les ARS et
donc connaît la remontée des besoins et
peu distribuer dans les centres qui ont
qui ont besoin
voilà et en mars
2022 et phaco en 2022 on a fabriqué 4 4
nouveaux voilà et la question pourrait
se poser peut se poser de savoir si
effectivement cette
présentation avec une contraction en
double de ce qui existe sur le marché
actuellement pourraient faire l'objet
d'un partenariat pour être mené à la MM
puisque c'est du 10 mg ml et que ça
n'existe pas sur le marché aujourd'hui
voilà donc
juste une question par rapport à ce que
vous avez dit pour être sûr que j'ai
bien compris en tant que rapporteur
parce que vous voilà vous vous êtes
dedans vous voyez bien la fabrication
etc
à partir bon vous vous constatez enfin
vous vous analysez mais que vous ne
pouvez pas produire donc ce curare pour
les raisons que vous avez donné
sur les machines et tout donc les les
pays étudient et développe des méthodes
de fabrication qui vont permettre
effectivement comme vous l'avez dit de
sauver des vies et vous dites en fait
c'est sous le vocal ou de préparation
hospitalière et à ce moment là pour
qu'on soit bien d'accord
les préparations hospitalières telles
que là sur ce produit il n'y a pas
besoin d'un mm
donc c'est pour ça que ça va plus vite
j'ai maman mon propos
en collaboration avec DELF armes on a eu
des échanges d'un point de vue technique
pharmaceutique et prise de
responsabilité de ma part parce que
c'est moi qui est libéré les lots
effectivement tout n'a pas été fait dans
le cadre strict du respect des bonnes
pratiques de fabrication et de la même
donc c'est une voilà c'est pour toujours
être sûr donc ce genre de de méthode que
vous faites comme ça en fait ça ne peut
se faire ou ça peut se faire donc en
situation d'urgence mais est-ce qu'on
peut penser
généraliser à des à une situation
j'allais dire normale parce que on est
en situation normale mais en même temps
avec des pénuries très très fortes donc
est-ce que ce genre de pratique peut
être généralisé quand on voit toutes les
molécules aujourd'hui qui sont atteintes
de de problèmes de tension ou de pénurie
non puisque encore une fois on tombe sur
le sujet de concurrence la vocation de
l'établissement favastatique n'est et de
produire que ce qui manque aujourd'hui
on est en train de discuter beaucoup la
liste de médicaments indispensables
ressortent toujours le propose
jusqu'à preuve du contraire ils ont été
en tension parce que crise
exceptionnelle pendant le covid mais ils
ont habituellement contrairement par
exemple ils ne sont pas en tension ni en
rupture ni en tension donc c'est vrai
qu'on est dans champ concurrentiel et
aujourd'hui au vu du statut
d'établissement pharmaceutique on n'a
pas vocation on n'est pas autorisé à
faire ses préparations hospitalières par
contre on pourrait en situation de crise
ou de préparation de crise il y a
l'article 61 a de financement qui crée
ce statut intermédiaire de PHS donc on
préparation hospitalière spéciale alors
même qui a une mm qui existe mais qui
n'est pas disponible soit parce qu'il y
a un choc de demande crise sanitaire
soit la choc d'offre l'usine du
fournisseur est rasé et fermé parce que
mon lit mesure de police sanitaire ou
canal de Suez bloqué où là on sera sans
doute autorisé à faire et c'est
là-dessus qu'on se positionne
dans le cadre de l'article 61 du PLFSS
[Musique]
la taille des lots n'a rien à voir nous
les les qu'on fabrique sont des morts
c'est des petits lots quand même pour
l'industriel c'est du 5000 à 20000
ampoules une P8 c'est de la dizaine à la
centaine d'unités donc c'est pas du tout
chaque CHU avec sa P8 pouvait fabriquer
aujourd'hui
en fait il y a eu il y a eu deux temps
sollicitations par les pouvoirs publics
de la capacité à fabriquer
l'établissement pharmaceutique a été
sollicité comme les pharmacies exagères
on a dit nous étions industriels on peut
pas le faire dans nos ateliers les pays
ont eu cette réactivité c'est en sac
dans le cadre d'un réseau dans lequel on
croit ils sont un maillot qui est
indispensable ils ont fait les premiers
lots pour les besoins propres de leur
propre patients qui sont pas allés
vendre ils sont pas les distribués aux
établissements voisins c'était vraiment
pour le réa ils ont eu cette souplesse
là parce que c'est pas les mêmes nombre
réglementaires et ils font du manuel
donc il y a pas ce sujet industriel
c'est une chance et en plus ça nous a
permis très vite ils ont fait la preuve
de concept ils ont mis en stabilité ce
qui nous après nous a permis de
construire des méthodes analytiques et
de s'engager sur sur la stabilité des
produits au moment de la distribution et
puis la deuxième étape ça a été au-delà
des quelques centaines d'ampoules ou
milliers d'ampoules faites pour les
besoins propres des quelques CHU qui ont
réussi à produire il fallait
l'industrialiser ce travail de skylob de
passage à l'industrie les pays étaient
pas capables en capacité de le faire
c'est notre expertise à nous op on ne
pouvait pas le faire dans nos ateliers
pour la raison qu'on vous exprimé et
donc on s'est tourné vers un
sous-traitant et le schéma qu'on
envisage dans le cadre d'une gestion de
crise articles 61 c'est plutôt celui-là
c'est mobilisé la réactivité des pays
l'expertise industrialisation et prise
de responsabilité du pharmacien
responsable sur voilà l'analyse bénéfice
crise et quel est le niveau de qualité
que l'on se fixe en lien bien sûr et
sous contrôle de la NSM et ensuite on
s'adresse en façonnière sous-traitant
pour pour le pour le volume pour le
volume industriel
c'est indispensable d'avoir un travail
en équipe
un bel exemple effectivement de travail
en équipe à la fois avec les
institutions et les autorités à une sm
DGS les collègues des pharmacies à usage
intérieur et nous-mêmes et aussi les
industriels tels que des femmes puisque
c'est des femmes qui a fabriqué les
ampoules
moi j'ai quelques questions
complémentaires
on recensé 150 personnes qui
travaillaient pour pour la GEP en 2016
on est à quel effectif actuellement
je vais finir mes questions et puis et
puis vous parlerai dans le micro pour
que ce que ça puisse être enregistré
est-ce que est-ce que le le choix de ne
plus produire et un caractère
complètement irréversible ou à l'aune de
ce que vous avez vécu pour pour les
curare vous considérez que finalement ce
qui s'est mis en place peut pallier
toutes les carences bon ce qu'on voit
pas tout à fait en ce moment puisque la
pénurie persiste elle est même
croissante puisque on n'est pas
stabilisé sur sur un certain nombre de
Médicis médicaments essentiels donc
est-ce que est-ce que dans vos
réflexions à vous vous considérez que ça
pourrait quand même se défendre d'avoir
une forme d'autonomie de production à
plus grande échelle
pour régler la question des pénuries ou
alors un pôle public qui
ferait le lien entre les pharmacies
internes entre vous
les hôpitaux Lyon la pharmacie centrales
les armées enfin pourquoi pas enfin un
ensemble une espèce de structuration à
l'échelle nationale pour pouvoir
répondre
dans l'urgence parce que ça fait à peu
près trois mois qu'il y a plus
d'amoxicilline ou parfois une fois de
temps en temps dans une disponible dans
une officine et puis il y a pas la
semaine d'après donc voilà on n'est pas
non plus on n'est pas c'est pas la
question des curare mais enfin ça
pourrait devenir quand même assez assez
fondamental et cruel comme d'ailleurs
tout ce qui concerne les les antalgiques
ça c'est ma deuxième question et et ma
troisième question et porte sur sur la
fameuse ammap HP c'est quoi le statut de
cet amphp parce que
qui qui décrète c'était même est-ce que
c'est la NSM est-ce qu'il existe
d'autres A&M Haddock comme ça en France
ou alors est-ce que la PHP compte tenu
du fait qu'elle
voilà l'APHP
à ses propres A&M et peu d'ailleurs à
partir de ses propres
ammén générés des interactions avec le
privé et derrière un retour financier
comme vous l'avez justement dit pour
faire fonctionner la GEPS je vous
remercie
alors sur les sur les effectifs
c'est le bon chiffre 180 au total sur
l'établissement alors le Global aGEPS
pardon c'est 480
aujourd'hui les 6 départements compris
on doit être à 120
il y avait que 35 personnes qui étaient
dédiées à la production
la production fonctionne toujours donc
les personnes il y a des personnes
encore en prod elles fonctionnent pas
tout à fait comme avant puisque vous
avez soustraité donc on aimerait bien
comprendre ce qu'on fait et ce qu'on ne
fait plus à la GEPS est-ce que la jette
pouvait faire jusqu'à présent et
permettez quand même quelque part de se
projeter dans le devenir d'une
production
sur un pôle public qui se structurerait
pas uniquement autour de la jette mais
quand même
où la javs j'aurais son rôle et parce
que 35 personnes du coup on s'étonne
en fait les 120 on est sur l'ensemble de
l'établissement pharmaceutique
et puis ensuite on va parler sur du
périmètre que l'on va sous-traiter donc
120 c'est au total les concerné par le
projet de d'externalisation de la moitié
récente de nos productions une centaine
de TP un petit peu moins 80
et par rapport à ces 80 le projet c'est
de supprimer les postes rendre les
postes correspondant vraiment à
l'activité de production donc
essentiellement ouvriers de production
et puis les techniciens de laboratoire
qui font le contrôle qualité donc au
final la cible que l'on s'est fixée et
qui est en cours de de réalisation c'est
c'est environ entre 40 et 50 TP
organisé en fait en quadrimante
d'expertise donc pharmaceutique
ingénierie logistique et contrôle
qualité
spécialisée par portefeuille de produits
et de sous-traitants
donc on passe on vous passeriez à 40 ou
50 TP
dans un futur relativement proche
c'était le plan de charge qui a fait des
idées par la PHP en 2018 c'est ça sur
défini que ça en discussion avec l'État
c'était pas que un choix unique de
l'APHP ou
non non c'était un choix à PHP puisqu'on
était vraiment
de discussions d'interaction avec le
ministère non on a régulièrement discuté
avec la DGS avec la NSM sur de nos
problématiques de d'activité la nature
de nos produits le statut d'exploitation
de ces produits donc voilà ça c'est fait
les uns et les autres étaient informés
mais c'est vrai que c'est pas une
codécise la décision a été arrêtée au
niveau de l'Assistance publique sachant
qu'encore une fois l'idée est vraiment
de continuer notre activité et non pas
et de la développer plutôt que
on part de 120 on part de 120 personnes
on aboutit on aboutit attendez on
aboutit à 45 TP et vous parlez en même
temps ce que j'ai entendu tout à l'heure
de redéploiement concernant la recherche
or redéploiement concernant la recherche
ça ne va pas être les mêmes personnes
que celle que vous allez licencier parce
que non ce sont là excusez-moi ce sont
des ouvriers spécialisés etc sont pas
obligatoirement des chercheurs donc vous
n'êtes pas sur le même profil donc ça
veut dire que
enfin c'est énorme 120 tomber à 40 quand
même
on n'entend pas 40
on tombe à 40 on passe de 80 en gros à
40 ou 50 sur la partie le périmètre
d'externalisation donc production dans
nos ateliers et contrôle qualité
on a un département à faire
réglementaire qui n'est pas touché on a
un département contrôle qualité
et vas-y faire le pitch
120 personnes si département d'accord
parmi ces 6 départements il y en a un
qui est le drdp donc les départements
recherchent pharmaceutique et
développement qui n'est pas touché c'est
celui qui est concerné par
l'augmentation qui va être renforcée on
a le département des essais cliniques
qui n'est pas touché donc tous les
essais cliniques promus par la paix qui
nécessite d'ailleurs vu l'ampleur et
l'augmentation en sua la suite de la
covid du nombre de ces cliniques d'être
sans doute renforcés c'est une réflexion
qui est en cours
et donc sont concernés quatre
départements deux essentiels qui sont le
département contrôle qualité le
département de production industrielle
puisque c'est là qu'on a les ouvriers en
production industrielle qui font de la
production actuelle toujours et le DC
culte département de contrôle qualité où
il y a les techniciens de contrôle
qualité les deux autres départements qui
sont moins impactés mais qui sont dans
le PC voilà le
Département Qualité
qui lui aura son périmètre qui a pas
raison qui bouge beaucoup et par contre
il y a un autre département sur lequel
on est en cours de réflexion qui est pas
impacté au jour d'aujourd'hui en termes
de de TP c'est le département réglement
des Affaires Réglementaires par la suite
et médical le darpem
qui est un petit département mais pour
lequel qui gère donc la
pharmacovigilance l'information médicale
etc et qui va sans doute enfin qui a
pour moi a besoin à être renforcé donc
les deux départements qui sont
principalement impactés sont le DPI et
le dcq et donc sur les quatre
départements concernés au jour
d'aujourd'hui on est à 80 TP environ et
effectivement c'est 80 qui vont passer à
de ce qu'on a évalué donc voilà
parmi 120 il y en a que 80 qui sont
concernés et donc sur l'idée d'un pôle
quand même parce que entre temps c'est
passé la covid vous avez été comment
dire par acquisitionner mais sur
instruction des pouvoirs publics on nous
a demandé de jouer un rôle particulier
pour la question des curare par exemple
mais ça pourrait être une demande à
l'avenir est-ce que depuis il y a une
réflexion à la demande notamment des
pouvoirs publics de la NSM de la DGS du
ministère pour que ce roi soit remis en
cause cette marche
irréversible vers
le fait que vous ne puissiez plus
répondre à terme à ce qui vous a été
demandé là on parlait des productions
propres par la Régie donc en
l'occurrence pour le six à curium
c'était je dirais
puisque ça a été fait en sous-traitance
par les pharmacies internes des hôpitaux
dont vous dites justement que c'est pas
tout à fait dans les mêmes conditions
que si ça avait été produit je de
manière strictement
académique du point de vue sanitaire
dans à l'ajeps ça c'est la première
étape il a fallu faire effectivement la
preuve concept et les pays ont une
vélocité que effectivement
l'établissement pharmaceutique qu'il
soit privé ou public non pas ça c'est
important
et ça a été fait engager quand je dis
enregistre c'est chez delfarm c'est là
où on a besoin des sous-traitants pour
la partie la production industrielle en
plus de ça deux éléments si attracturium
produit froid plus de plus 8 et produit
avec filtration terrasse répartition
acétique que tout le monde n'a pas et
voilà c'est à la fois technique les
instruments enfin les équipements etc
du contenu si on n'a pas tout à fait
répondu
la réversibilité en questionne
régulièrement mais encore enfin au
quotidien on
avance sur la mise en sous-traitance de
nos productions mais non on envisage pas
une réversibilité de cette décision qui
est déjà très avancée
où encore une fois la diversité du
besoin nous incite plutôt à croire à une
organisation réseau plutôt qu'une
production en propre donc c'est plutôt
confirmé mais encore une fois faut
jamais dire jamais ou en tout cas
aujourd'hui la décision la position
c'est plutôt celle-ci par contre ceux en
quoi on croit sur lequel on se
positionne très clairement alors je sais
pas s'il faut l'appeler Paul public et
s'il établissement pharmaceutique il
suffit à lui seul mais très clairement
dans le cadre de l'article 61 de son
décret d'application
on envisage de reproduire ce qui a
plutôt bien marché pour le 6
attracturium et donc il est prévu que
des pays ou des établissements
pharmaceutiques sont autorisés à et
ensuite produit par produit il y a une
demande de la part des pouvoirs publics
et donc dans ce contexte là si on est
sollicité on envisageait tout à fait de
jouer le rôle que l'on a joué dans le
cas du six attaques c'est à dire
mobiliser à la demande des GS à NSM dans
un premier temps les pays pour l'épreuve
de concept dans un deuxième temps les
façonniers avec qui on travaille au
quotidien pour notre propre production
et les articles de conditionnement et
autres donc voilà le pôle public tel que
nous on envisage en tout cas et c'est la
proposition de service que fait le DG de
l'AP-HP c'est de reproduire en routine
ce qu'on a pu faire un six attractions
en anticipant parce que plutôt que
d'attendre trouver la matière première
c'est maintenant qu'on a une liste de
médicaments sensibles il faut pas
qu'elle soit trop trop extensive mais
dès lors qu'on a cette Alice l'idée
c'est d'avoir d'un côté des réflexe ou
des recettes de cuisine pour parler à
vulgairement par produit avoir une
petite idée de où on va en termes de
méthodes de développement et de
formulation qui intéresse tout le monde
donc ça et ça sente ici
quel type de contenance ou de
conditionnement primaires en a quelle
formule on choisit et puis en face de ça
parce qu'on connaît bien les façonner
mais pas seulement avoir un carnet
d'adresse finalement et arriver à peu
près à propositionner par avance en
anticipant les situations de tension
savoir à qui s'adresser pour produire
telle ou telle formule et ça
effectivement on pense pouvoir le faire
du fait des expériences réussissent ils
s'attaqueront mais puis la culture
établissement pharmaceutique que l'on a
depuis plusieurs années sur nos produits
ou sur la reprise de produits qu'on a
demandé de reprendre
la conception du pôle public
on l'imagine effectivement comme plutôt
une coordination effectivement
différents acteurs nécessaires à pouvoir
fabriquer
des médicaments quand besoin
et et
il est indispensable essentiel que ça
soit anticipé avec le 6 attraquarium je
dirais que nous avons eu de la chance
il y avait du six attracterium il y
avait les pays alors ça les existent
toujours
nous on est là on est toujours là même
si on change de façon de faire les
productions et il y a les CDMO les
façonniers qui sont encore là donc
effectivement il faut organiser tout ça
en amont ce qui manque aujourd'hui et ce
qui a été crucial quand même pendant le
la crise de la covid pas que pour le 6
attraquarium pour d'autres produits
c'est les IP i les principes actifs ça
il faut réinternaliser la synthèse
il faut pouvoir produire la synthèse
ou être en mesure de
et alors on
en est au gouvernement
moi je suis pour vous
pour le moment laps fabriquée des
principes actifs où elle ne l'a jamais
fait
vous avez de la chimie voilà c'était ça
on a eu un moment donné mais écoutez
j'ai commencé mon internat en 89
effectivement il y avait un chimiste
organicien qui était prof à la fac qui
voilà qui était en capacité de mais il
avait il avait pas de il y avait pas de
quoi faire
la biologie c'est c'est bien
l'écart-tisèle c'est extraordinaire mais
si vous n'avez pas de chimie vous faites
pas alors ce qu'il faut avoir à l'esprit
aussi c'est que
il y a des molécules simples à fabriquer
qui demande de 3 réactions et puis il y
a des molécules plus compliquées les
glugattes enfin les cortics quoi qu'ils
sont en haute tension voir en rupture
sont
un problème c'est 30 à 40 réactions
effectivement donc ça oui pour
réinternaliser la chimie en France on a
eu des grands groupes voilà il y a et on
a plusieurs on a plusieurs
on a séquence on a nous travaillons avec
accentis avec ceratet qui il y a des
synthétiseurs en France il faut leur
donner les moyens de pouvoir développer
des nouvelles techniques de synthèse
plus performante on parle de chimie en
flux
en terme de rendement parce que ça va
diminuer les coûts
et deuxièmement il y a l'environnement
durable c'est quand même un sujet voilà
et ce qui fait la grosse différence
entre l'Inde la Chine et je veux dire
l'Europe les États-Unis
il y a la main d'oeuvre certes mais il y
a l'environnement durable ils ont rien à
faire de l'environnement durable
et nous c'est ça génère des des coups
que voilà
alors les principes actifs n'oubliez pas
que pour faire un principe actif aux
différents composants donc il faut avoir
ce qu'on appelle les Romains
si vous n'avez pas d'acide acétique si
vous avez pas de chloroforme il apporte
quoi je sais pas chimiste mais voilà
vous pourrez pas fabriquer la moxissive
ou le cura
1 il faut pouvoir avoir des excipients
quand on fabrique des comprimés ou des
gélules il y a pas que il y a les
gélules par exemple qui sont en tension
en termes de de d'approvisionnement là
j'ai lu le vide dans lequel vous allez
mettre les principes actifs et les
excipients et puis les articles de
conditionnement
vous avez pas d'ampoule c'est pas de
flacon pas de bouchon vous faites pas de
médicaments
et après il faut effectivement un réseau
un tissu industriel mais on l'a de CDMO
qui soit capable de fabriquer à peu près
toutes les formes nécessaires
merci
Annick une question et puis Laurence
cohenic oui merci Madame la prédire
rapide parce qu'il nous reste peu de
temps en fait oui oui elle sera très
courte je m'adresserai plus
spécifiquement Monsieur Bernard vous
avez dit tout à l'heure dans la fabrique
du 6 à 3 curium que vous aviez pu lancer
la fabrication relativement rapidement
parce que vous aviez entre guillemets
pris vos responsabilités
est-ce que ce que je trouve tout à fait
bien
est-ce que vous pensez que dans certains
cas de pénuries de médicaments il y en a
qui n'osent pas ou qui ou est-ce qu'on a
un système réglementaire ou
administratif trop rigide qui peut
justement favoriser ces ruptures
c'est compliqué
oui je voulais dire que en vous
entendant c'est vraiment très très
intéressant et en même temps on a quand
même un peu l'impression que même si il
faut se redéployer j'ai bien compris
mais quelque part vous vous privez quand
même de et vous nous vous et vous nous
c'est pas vous en tant que tel mais vous
nous et puis bon ce sont aussi les
directives qui vous sont qui vous sont
donnés mais de savoir faire parce que à
partir du moment où on passe à un tel à
moindreissement on va dire des effectifs
et on le voit on l'a vu dans nos
auditions non il y a les grands labos
qui font pareil c'est un savoir-faire
qui est perdu une terriblement donc
quelque part on se met une balle dans le
pied ça c'est juste une appréciation
personnelle mais vous n'avez pas répondu
à la continuité des soins
comment est-ce que vous faites par
rapport à ça donc ça c'était une
question à laquelle vous n'avez pas
répondu voilà voilà
on fait ça dans quel ordre
merci
c'est compliqué parce que ça dépend du
du problème si on reste strictement dans
le dans le cadre d'une
épié des points liés aux bonnes
pratiques de fabrication
au niveau de de
d'exigence
qu'il faut à au Californie
par exemple il y a la ligne directrice
numéro 1 qui vient d'être modifiée sur
les produits injectables qui faisaient
10 pages et l'en fait plus de 50 voilà
après il y a des choses qui sont c'est
une prise de
c'est une prise de décision
pharmaceutique parce que c'est technique
et donc ça dépend de la du problème là
par exemple pour les cureurs normalement
on doit qualifier les filtres avec
différents tests etc et on a pris la
responsabilité de de sa fille infiltre
ça filtre quand même même si voilà mais
on n'a pas pris le temps de les
qualifier parce que ça nous aurait amené
dans des délais extraordinaires bon
voilà c'est
les aspects techniques c'est et c'est au
cas au cas par cas et ça dépend de la
personne qui prend les responsabilités
aussi qui prend la décision une fille je
peux pas me mettre à la place d'un
collègue qui aura les mêmes décisions il
aurait peut-être pas pris la même pas
moi j'ai partagé je prends jamais de
décision tout seul enfin la décision est
finie je la prends tout c'est moi qui la
prend mais forcément j'en parle à droite
avec
si j'ai enfin voilà
c'est la bonne ou pas la bonne
en routine enfin on a le degré
d'exigence qualité et réglementaire déjà
c'est des normes européennes et non pas
française on a le degré de qualité ou de
d'exigence de sécurité que demande la
société aussi donc ça c'est pour la
routine et après pendant la crise je
pense que tout le monde sous l'exemple
de ces attaques tout le monde a appris
ces responsabilités nous faire un bout
de chaîne sur la sous-traitance mais en
amont la NSM qui a vraiment contribué à
proposer une formulation à contrôler
dans ses laboratoires donc elle a été
vraiment partie prenante les pays ont
pris leur part donc voilà je crois que
ça a été un beau partage de
responsabilité même si infini l'échelle
industrielle c'est ça a reposé sur
l'établissement en pharmacie de
l'éthique de l'AP-HP
juste ça fait sous les AMAP HP non c'est
pas une spécifique c'est pas une
spécificité je vous ai pas répondu sur
les mêmes PHP donc on en a quelques unes
on Alfort épisodes on a on en a
certaines qui on a en partenariat
industriel mais on est titulaire la
méthadone c'est c'est le cas non tout
établissement pharmaceutique où il y a
même pas besoin d'être établissement
pharmaceutique d'ailleurs pour pour être
titulaire d'AMM et donc percevoir des
royalties ou des redevances sur sur ces
mêmes nous on estime plutôt que un
intérêt à faire la titularité et
l'exploitation parce que c'est des
sujets pharmaceutiques être justitaire
d'une amie c'est pas juste un brevet
encore une fois c'est pas c'est pas
vendre de la soupe et être et faire du
commerce c'est ces pharmaceutique même
lorsqu'on est que titulaire sachant que
c'est une distinction qui n'existe qu'en
France titularité exploitable
exploitation
sur le l'organisation et la gestion des
pénuries
la priorisation des patients on
travaille sur les équivalents
thérapeutiques donc la première étape
c'est trouver des fournisseurs de
substituts
pendant la crise covid on a été pas mal
proactif avec la DGS mais mais la paix à
travailler directement on a trouvé des
fournisseurs ou des choses
d'approvisionnement éloignées y compris
au Japon
et après c'est au sein de la PHP
effectivement on travaille sur les
économies donc sur la crise covid on a
fait des des doctrines d'économie sur la
curarisation on a privilégié midazolam
plutôt sur certains patients de mémoire
long séjour et réserver le propos folle
à ce qui était le plus aigu puisque bien
sûr il y avait la crise covid il fallait
aussi prendre en charge et son palliatif
les soins de longue durée
donc voilà il y a forcément des choix
qui sont faits mais encore une fois ils
sont faits sont collégiales et en
pluridisciplinarité puisque un des
enjeux plus globaux sur le marché des
médicaments c'est que on fait du
développement on a des produits de plus
en plus innovants à des prix faramineux
parfois on peut s'interroger sur le
service en réel rendu mais c'est
pathologies peuvent pathologies souvent
donc c'est vrai que à un moment donné on
essaye à la paix de faire en sorte que
ça soit pas telle maladie rare qu'il
soit plus tard que telle maladie rare
par rapport aux centaines de patients en
AVC ou en infarctus
et c'est cette intégration qui voilà qui
fait la richesse qui fait la richesse de
la structure
une toute petite dernière question 2,5
milliards d'euros par an c'est
dispositifs médicaux et médicaments et
donc la part des médicaments c'est
combien les sur notre dépense de
médicaments à la paix enfin au marché
alors cette 2 milliards je
plutôt 2 milliards lors de grandeur et
c'est non non c'est tout confondu DM et
molécules
médicaments on est autour de 1
milliards
en fonction des thérapies et des
molécules on a eu un pic à un milliard 8
avec les Antilles CV et puis on est
redescendu non non mais c'est important
puisque la ligne médicament du PLFSS
n'est pas concerné par ce 1 milliard
deux un milliard 8
ok merci
merci à vous merci à vous c'est une
commission d'enquête donc c'était un peu
sous le feu des questions mais on veut
des choses très précises dans nos
réponses voilà et on va vous envoyer un
questionnaire complémentaire auquel vous
vous voudrez bien nous répondre et puis
je vous remercie voilà de la qualité de
de vos réponses puisque finalement c'est
plutôt une actualité récente le devenir
de la jette dans sa nouvelle
configuration et entre temps il y a
quand même eu un événement plutôt majeur
et entre temps il y a une aggravation
plutôt majeure aussi des pénuries de
médicaments et donc légitimement on
attendait de cette audition d'avoir un
échange un peu à bâton rompu et nous
donne des informations un peu ferme sur
sur la question du rejoué par chacun sur
ce sujet là je vous remercie beaucoup
merci à vous merci à vous